Putin has a secret private Army called  the Wagner group they don't even  officially exist in Russia instead  they're registered in Argentina it's run  by an ex-russian Special Forces officer  who's an extremely rich oligarch with  very close ties to Putin why does Putin  need a secret army simple whenever Putin  needs some dirty work done in a foreign  country he can send in these unmarked  Wagner troops they'll do the Dirty Work  and boom none of it can be traced back  to Putin and Russia can't be accused of  committing an act of war or committing  certain crimes they've been hired to  assassinate Ukraine's president multiple  times and they've been deployed to  interfere in The Civil Wars of countries  all over the world from Syria to Sudan  to Libya Venezuela Mozambique and More  in exchange for helping out in these  Civil Wars Russia gets access to tons of  Natural Resources in these places and  Putin gets some new puppets it's no  wonder that